i recently saw a picture of you
at a knicks game you were sitting with i
think pete davidson and who was the
other person there next jon stewart yeah
the great jon stewart the three of you i
don't know if you all just ended up
sitting next to each other or you plan
to go together he texted me and said hey
we're i'm gonna cause he and john go to
the games a lot and sit together okay
they're friends yeah and then i was
texting with pete about something and he
said hey i'm going to the game
do you want to come with me and john
i was like oh yeah i'll do that yeah
that sounds like fun yeah what are you
making since you worked on saturday
night live briefly and and certainly
you've you've directed and you've done
it all in show business now what do you
make of pete davidson and we hear he's
dating up the star these women can't
stay away from him pete is having a
moment in
time right now
he's an incredibly sweet guy have you
talked to him ever have you met him oh
yeah we've had him on the show a couple
of times i like him very much he's so
personable you know he's got such a
charisma he's funny he's really funny
um but he has become really really
famous i think
you know for
kind of dating yes and and and being on
the show but he and i think he re i get
the sense he's a guy who like really
loves to work cares about his work
and that's where you know i think that's
how he's going to be known he's got a
lot of great work ahead of him too but
he's really funny on the show too like
he's able to go on
weekend update and do what he does he's
doing him right it's not that easy to
just be that funny and interesting and
likeable going you know to do that you
come on do a character do a thing but
he's really like taking his life and
he's turning it into you know
to material but do you think that he can
do that because his life now has become
so public and so outrageous but that
kind of led to him being able to be
himself
i think he was doing i think that's why
he became popular i think that's why
people were attracted to watching him on
the show and you know he just has a real
charm about him and he i think he really
wants to act and do you know and he's
making movies and you know taking roles
on that are real acting roles